لا للكروش في صفوف الجيش العراقي هذا ما
وجه به رئيس اركان الجيش في العراق موجها
بفحص اوزان الضباط واحاله المترهلين منهم
الى التقاعد
القرار يلقى قبولا كبيرا من قبل جمهور
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاعتبارات
العسكريه متعلقه بالرشاقه والقوه البدنيه
ليجد الكثيرون ان غالبيه عناصر الجيش
العراقي بعد عام 2003 يعانون السنه
والبدانه وهذا يخالف الشروط التي يجب ان
يتصل بها الضابط او العنصر المنتمي لهذه
المؤسسات
من جديد هو احتمال ضابط كفو يعني حرامات
بشكل عام ضروري يكون ضابط مسوي دايت يعني
هو يعني عمله يحتاج الى سرعه حركه بالتالي
يعني مع هذا القرار لانه بالتالي هم
واجهتنا هم الواجهه اللي تمثل هذا الشعب
من الناحيه الصحيه ما ممكن
لا يستطيع التحرك من مكانه كيف يستطيع ان
يتحرك في معركه ضد عناصر الارهابيه لا
سيما ما زالت هناك بقايا من عندها من جهه
اخرى يلاقي الق
رار لدى البعض فيصفون الوزاره بالكارهه
للبدانه كما يرى اخرون ان هذا القرار يشكل
نوعا من التنمر ممن يعانون السمنه